all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to the pre-game everyone class
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and guys this is
the first episode under the audacity
Network so we have started a new network
where we are signing YouTube Talent we
are the best in the game the we have the
audacity to have freedom of speech we
have the audacity to speak out against
woke culture so therefore we are called
The Audacity Network here is our logo so
if you guys want to apply to work at the
audacity Network make sure you go to my
Instagram just pearlythings1 or email me
at justpirelythings gmail.com either as
Talent or management we're hiring for
both
um so yeah welcome to the show everybody
um today we have a lovely group of
ladies
um and one guy
poor guy
yeah sorry
um so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age relationship
status and what you do for a live thing
so starting here and then go around
hey everyone my name is Raquel M Jackson
I am a set decorator so I work in
reality TV talk shows theater and I am
in a relationship and I am 44 years old
and show them the shirt I gave you
oh Lord here we go guys yeah show them
the shirt I get I made shirts and so
that that one is the Barbie Edition so I
put it in the Barbie font um yeah we're
gonna sell those soon so go ahead
um my name is Kyra Simone
um my age you can pay me if you want to
know that and also um I'm an agency
owner on an amazing platform called bigo
live pretty successful on there you'll
see me on like three different
Billboards on magazines on BuzzFeed all
that I do my big one
um and what else did you want me to say
name and relationship status my
relationship status it depends on who's
asking okay wait I need to I need to
break that down why do we like that so
are you
so are you with someone like someone you
like
no it literally just depends on who's
asking speak to me well oh sorry well
I'm just wondering if you have a
boyfriend or not it literally depends on
who's asking okay so if an ugly guy asks
you have a boyfriend if a handsome guy
asks you don't exactly and either one is
kind of just like whatever it is it is
okay do you do you think that'd be a
little confusing for a guy yeah but that
doesn't matter that's up to me okay well
I know it's up to you but I'm just
wondering like yeah you know because if
a guy if a guy said if I said do you
have a girlfriend and he's like depends
who's asking I'm like do you have a
girlfriend
no of course you're gonna get like
irritated with it but at the same time
that's my business and if you're not
doing anything to court me to get in
that situation that I don't owe you
anything I just wonder why as women we
have these confusing answers instead of
just like answering questions directly
because guys do I don't I really don't
think that's true they do because I've
done I've done hundreds of these shows
and I've never had a guy give me an
answer like that it's either single
taken sometimes they might say I'm
seeing someone but like it's very a lot
more clear than the women in general I
haven't done hundreds of these shows but
I've done thousands of people
approaching me okay that's the thing and
the men so what are the answers the men
usually give like a man when they're
like like coming for me I'm just like do
you have anybody at home well baby we
ain't even talking about that right now
I've heard that before
so so so yes they do yeah but it's like
I can't do it too so like I'm one of
those people if you think I could do it
too well yeah but then you're trying to
be a guy and no I'm not trying to be a
guy I'm just trying to have an even
platform that's the problem is a lot of
people try to think that like I'm trying
to be a guy I'm not it's just like if
you could do it why do the why do you
think that you can do it just because
you're a man and I can't do it because
I'm a female so my question is you said
that the men need to court you but they
can't Court you if you don't give them
an answer if you're in a relationship or
not most of them don't even ask to be I
don't even they don't care
do you feel like you deal with
traditional men hell no well okay there
you go there you go yeah but I'm saying
like because traditional mental ass like
men that are trying to court you they'll
ask no and I agree with you yeah but
like there you go traditional people are
starting I'm sorry the traditional men
are starting to like extinct if like
anybody knows they literally they don't
care about nothing they're like okay you
you know like I'm just trying to date
you do you want to and then the
next one once that's not a traditional
guy though no no not traditional sorry
I'm into non-traditional guys that like
approach you or like uh like who are you
would you like to and after that
can you take care of me why do all these
guys nowadays but it's like why do you
deal with the guys that want to be taken
care of I don't but then how would you
know this because you wouldn't know this
information because they approached me
well but then why are broke guys
approaching you you know what I'm saying
like it's like
everywhere
because I'm hot I can't stop anybody
from like but I'm saying like
traditional guys are going to be turned
off by that answer because like
traditional guys don't want to deal with
the so it's like you're almost
like adapting for the non-traditional
guys you know what I'm saying like and
it's gonna turn off someone that's
traditional because they're like are you
taking are you not this is too confusing
on to the next I 100 agree with you but
what I do is I read the room just the
same way as I'm a VIP host out here I
know the kind of people that I can
proposition of buying bottle service at
the club because they can afford it I
could tell by your shoes by your watch
by your shoes who I can approach about
buying bottle service at a club the same
way that I can like show who I'm gonna
do that answer to somebody who is like
not worth my time is what who gets that
answer but somebody who's traditional
probably worth my time but will never
get there well you know well but you
realize like traditional like I have 1.7
million subscribers and a lot of the
guys that watch are in a more
traditional mindset so it's like by
giving this answer you're basically
telling them you're not a traditional
woman because traditional women don't
answer like that which is fine it
doesn't mean like bad person but I'm
saying like if you want to attract
traditional men the I just think they're
going to be confused that's also kind of
your opinion of the traditional guys
like the guys that like are like into
you you don't really know no actually
the objective truth is most of the guys
that are traditional and high value men
we look for a certain thing or a status
in a woman so if we're talking to a gal
and it's like they give us this vague
answer it's like okay she's seeing
somebody or not she won't give me an
answer and then it's like do I want to
deal with it right well yeah and then I
think they just think you're
yeah
it's like wait it depends on who's
asking it's like okay are you are you a
man or a woman well it depends on who's
asking it's like okay I'm just trying to
talk to you it's difficult never mind
right but I hear what you're saying but
I think that when you have that many
subscribers you deal with guys like that
that deal with women
I mean we some guys don't have to deal
with it some don't you know and I know
your bottle service I I get that no no
but I'm VIP I loan juice bottle service
I'm not the girl
I was so independent host yeah I'm
independent but I used to be at one Oak
exclusively okay but then I decided that
it's like a lot easier to ask my clients
where would you like to go right as
opposed to being like can you please
come here I know you really don't want
to come here but can you come here for
just me no that makes sense and like
honestly if you know anybody who's like
a VIP host we're trained to like really
read people sure and that's how I am so
like when I'm seeing those kind of
responses I'm saying that to the people
I know are jokes I don't say that to
people of what like oh yeah
but I mean girl I'm not I'm not gay I'm
not gonna you no shame right but
but I'm saying it's just I think I think
it's confusing to guys it's my only
Point all right what about you um
I know it keeps coming down I don't know
what else I can do because I keep
adjusting it but there you go
well don't make it come down here I'm
gonna try Okay testing can you hear me
yeah okay
um my name is Asia I am
25 years old and what was the other one
name age relationship status and what
you do for a living
name age
what I do for work right now I'm an
apprentice bartender for the MGM Grand
so that's really cool and
my relationship status is single
quick and simple black ice I host Black
Ice reality check and I run a tech
consulting company a supplement company
I am old
somebody double OG for you I'm 53 we'll
be 54 in October I've been in a
four-year relationship uh with my
girlfriend
actually actually was responsible for
getting these ladies here and we have
the relationship we've been on a couple
shows so yeah absolutely so it's got a
nice little podcast where he
he helps them out relationships
nice little podcast
[Laughter]
on me
hello
you know I got it in me you know I have
1.7 million subscribers
I did it I didn't I didn't mean it like
that
you know what's funny he's such a good
interviewer that I literally I messaged
you I wanted to come on you did I was
like I thought it was a joke at first no
I was serious I thought you were I was
like I love the way he talks to the
women I was like he does such a good job
of like
um saying it in a way that's like
doesn't make us want to like punch you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm already I'm already dead that's why
I had to sit over there I already saw it
from the beginning
yeah
I'm playing
I did I came in here with just like so
if you go I was like is he gonna kick me
out or not because you're gonna be like
Myron on fresh and fit I'm like
no shade go
so so I I interviewed ladies on
relationships single women and why
they're single or not what they're
looking for in a relationship they want
to get married and so I do what kind of
Kevin did but I do it in person yeah and
a different level right yeah and I think
it's really going to blow up I mean I I
literally
like yeah for now
[Laughter]
that's what all the women say I didn't
mean it I didn't mean it and we don't
have to agree on like every single thing
but it's about him being like all right
get the out
and I'm just like well was she
being a or not
I mean I like
a boss and you like can't like
handle a like that no I'm not even
no no no no but but I hear what you're
saying but there's a level of disrespect
when you're standing up yelling at
somebody it's like well he wasn't doing
anything I don't know who you're talking
about but I'm just saying okay I used to
actually think Myron was a dick I really
did and I feel bad because then I
actually got into his shoes and I
interviewed women and I did all these
shows and it's so crazy because you
don't see usually the level of
disrespect they'll do first yeah and
over talking someone on their own show
and feeling like they own the room and
then it's like by the time you kick them
out it's like they've over talked you
ten times have you you've kicked women
off your show yeah not I'm not as um
quick as Myron no you're like yeah I've
seen it yeah but it's like usually like
a lot of times they'll play the victim
and be like oh I saw the one that you
did with Andrew Tate and auntie and um
yeah
Brittany oh my God yeah that was a hard
one to watch but the the African girl
like the younger one not Auntie yeah
yeah yeah yeah she was crazy yeah it was
crazy after that she was like Pearl so
racist i'm like you've been on my
show three times
it was like but it's like a lot of times
when women get kicked off they just like
play the victim when it's like they
usually have like 10 different warnings
and then they get it was really
disrespectful I I watched that thing I
was actually surprised to be fair with
Myron he was talking over like the
whole goddamn time and then he just
wanted like to be able to pick on other
people like that so like honestly
like with you guys y'all completely just
disagree with my opinion but I never
felt offended one bit I felt like you're
entitled to your opinions and I
respected the hell out of it but the way
that he comes at people well and I'll
tell you I'll tell you what's happened
though I think women we've never really
had people talk to us in a more
masculine way because women just
policemen speech and like when we say
it's how you say it that's saying say it
in a more feminine way have you ever
been in a locker room with guys or like
in an all-male wait wait have you ever
been
she's over here
[Laughter]
I mean there's a reason we have phrases
like locker room talk right right
because men roast the hell out of each
other like they are they are so rude if
you're black you understand that because
you know yeah because it's it's every
day
it's not what you say it's how you say
it people are always correcting my tone
right all the time right is that women
correcting your toner man both it's it's
much when a man does that how does that
make you feel it makes you feel like
he's a yeah
yeah
right because it's a more feminine way
of talking right so I think with Myron
and I had this gut reaction to him at
first too but the thing is with him it's
like he's just speaking in a very
masculine direct way and most women have
never had guys talk to us I don't think
he's ever had the smacked out of
him I don't think it's a dirty he was a
federal agent yeah he's like a federal
agent do you think he's very scared of
some no no I'm saying like
you're like he never really got like
somebody who really stood there
you got damn as a federal agent it
doesn't matter if you're you could be a
president or you can be like a a
government official and when you get
somebody that you really respect that
tells you some then it like
it I saw him I saw him have someone like
come to his door and like threaten oh
yeah yeah I saw that I saw that I saw
that yeah I don't I don't know he stood
his ground he stood his ground yeah I
don't think it's like the darkness what
was that I don't think it's like the
directness of like how he is because I
think being direct is how he has to be
because unfortunately especially with
the room of women they start to over
talk everybody you have to command the
room and like calm it down I think
sometimes what it is is the the what
words you choose to use so like I've
heard him called girls and it
came out of nowhere and it's like whoa
like well usually they're being a
so I think that's I think that's what it
is so it's just like like let's say
you're talking to somebody because we're
not used to
Turner Michael because we're not used to
like the like you said like people
telling us what to do and holding
ourselves accountable
we always want you to be like well what
you did wasn't okay
usually what it is and so when we hear
somebody go say this they're like what
we want to we want to man up like what
the did you say to me yeah like
you're not gonna talk to me like that
right so yeah but and like that's kind
of what I've conditioned myself to like
when I hear guys speak in a very direct
way I have to ask myself first is it
true yeah so it's like was she being a
probably like all the girls I've
seen him kick off over talk to him at
least like four or five times and
there's an element of alcohol involved
there's a lot of them were drinking
before I'm like this girl
yes okay okay sorry so my name is Ashley
hi uh Ashley hi
do you want me to say my last name I
said hi okay hello she forgot the comma
Fabric and that was not a good one
um okay so my name is Ashley I'm 33
years old I am
I'm not I'm single but I'm not looking
because I'm dating somebody nice yeah
there we go and then uh it was a clear
answer that was indirect at first but
you made it very clear what I was gonna
say like he's not your boyfriend but you
like him yeah and then we're moving
towards that yeah okay great
um I was a bottle service girl X
powerlifter but now I work in a thousand
foot mine underground it's crazy I wear
a hard hat and steel toe boots and
everything
all right well my name is Yetta you had
a brown baby on social media I am 38 I'm
in a relationship with a woman I'm
bisexual but right now I'm in a
relationship with a wonderful lady
um I am a live streamer on Vigo and I
also have an agency social media has
been my thing for like the past 10 years
got hella followers on Facebook and on
Vigo and on Instagram now so much but
yeah
that's what I do
hi I'm Annie Annie are you okay on
social media I'm 28 I am currently
seeing someone but I'm open I'm dating
thank you for a living oh I work in Land
Management
government you govern land the
government jobs
so I have a question guys
do you think who do you think smarter
men or women women women
then why are so many of us and only fans
because why are so many men
Elon Musk Bill Gates where are they
we're so smart
hold on I haven't I have an answer to
that okay we don't give we don't we're
not given the chance this is the
opportunity I mean you could say that
all you want okay that's just the fact
and this is all women right here mine I
don't because I've been giving them
plenty of them okay so I've been in that
yeah I've been in the deployment
recruiting space for 28 years women have
a higher Advantage getting a job over a
man more black women have degrees in
Black Men the first millionaire woman in
America was black
right self-made women have more of
advantages than men to be successful
right so I don't know where and going
back to the only fans 92 percent of the
people on only fans are women not men
yeah because we know who's paying
exactly so but only fans doesn't have to
be just nudity you can take advantage of
this person I agree I agree because
initially I mean you could but we don't
like I did I mean initially when it came
out half a good mood I didn't have to
sleep with him would you what'd you do
on only fans I took cute pictures of her
feet
I did that as well okay so you so you
were so but you're still selling sex you
might you might not have taken off your
clothes but they're not they're not
looking at the only fans to be your
friend well they're looking for
something that's what only fans are
sports for exclusive content so if I
don't post on my Instagram or my
Facebook pictures and swimsuits cute
short dresses or whatever that is still
selling sex but it's from a different
perspective well yeah but I'm saying
you're still selling Beauty and I'm
saying if we're so smart why don't we
sell brains you can do that what about
we we can't we can but we don't right
God can't sell Beauty because they're
usually not beautiful why aren't they
selling more Beauty I just think that
like women are not gonna pay for it like
and like on only fans uh when a man
actually has an only fans account more
gay men are actually purchasing their
their content than it is women because
we're we're not going to pay for it yeah
no yeah but I'm saying like if we're
just these smart people it's like we
could go into physics
smarter not harder if you know you can
just take cute
women love the easy way not the hard way
and we just get naked instead of doing
the hard thing and men don't have the
opportunity to do that that's why they
have to work hard because nobody's going
to pay them correct correct and that's
why I think men are smarter than us
because they have to do I think when you
have to do harder things you become
smarter you know like if if you if you
have to study for a test and then you
have to take the test you become smarter
isn't it really true that the person who
didn't have to study and still got an A
is smarter than the one who had their
balls and that would be great if we were
good if we were getting A's I would
agree through school but it's so funny
it's so funny because we actually aren't
doing even though we have an advantage
because we can sell Beauty it's so funny
we make like 500 a month on only fans on
average we can't even sell sex the women
that make the most money on only fans
are managed by men if we were so smart
why can't even we why can't we sell our
own bodies better than men they're
making AI Bots yeah AI Bots yeah and so
it's like if we were really so smart why
can't we figure out how to do it go
ahead
um I happen to know a lot of the people
that work for managing of people they're
gay guys gay guys are nasty they know
how to talk they know exactly
what people wanted and I promise you
the people that you're talking to are
gay men all right but they're still men
yeah
but gay men are have the feminine side
they're tapped into their feminine
energy
it's not like a straight-ass men that
are managing and they're responding
there most of them but they're still men
like why like why can't the women figure
it out no they just don't want to they
don't want to talk like that
they're kind of disgusting so they know
what the disgusting that makes
money being able to relate to your
audience of course if men are the ones
in the market buying and stuff then of
course a guy's gonna know what to say
and how to Market it and what kind of
pictures they want shouldn't we know
since we've been like dating men our
whole lives don't we no shouldn't we
know what to say to men like if we're
the ones dating I think our emotions
like kind of get in the way of that
sometimes it's our hormone levels
everything like I mean they even said
like women that are on like birth
control like their hormone levels are
just crazy like you're more neurotic you
are not like almost like not yourself so
I and also that goes with the workforce
when they say oh like women and men are
not paid equally well we have less time
in the workforce because we have more
time off we have to get pregnant we have
periods sometimes people have to go home
and stay home because their periods are
so intense so it almost and men are
smarter I think hold on don't forget
bathrooms they love to like they
actually mention that on that um that
one movie about like the women who are
like you know doing the stuff in space
how like she had to take time to go to a
certain bathroom and how long it takes
us to go to the bathroom as opposed to
men all that stuff is factored as well
yeah that we have to go to the bathroom
for a long time that's holding us back
yeah longer than men they they factor in
20 and 2023. okay if I got a job at this
podcast Studio I think they'd hire me I
really do I think yeah and and I'd have
to walk to the bathroom there that's
gonna hold me back like as women we just
come up with excuses it's like excuse
Excuse excuse We're Men it's like you'll
have a guy in horrible working
conditions like on oil rigs Paving the
Pavements they don't complain women's
yeah yeah and we're we're in um we're in
the office like in these nice cushy jobs
and we still find something to whine
about okay I had a question how many men
do you is what you do you go down a
thousand feet on the ground and you see
aliens and stuff like that
they do experiments but it's no no
aliens nuclear stuff too yeah like that
how many how what's the what's a women
to men ratio there are you like the only
woman down there I am probably one of
like
four and there's more scientist women
there but there's but let's talk about
the labors the laborers it's like it's
probably like 99 men there you go yeah
yeah no but it's true they uh so they
did this like they did this like study
like a walking on the street study where
they asked men and women
um would you rather okay so it was like
would you rather work a high profile job
that pays nothing or would you rather
work in the sewers that pays a hundred
thousand dollars a year most women chose
a high profile job that pays nothing and
the men most of the men were like well
no I want the money so I'm going to work
in the sewers so it's like goes to show
you that like most women just kind of
want like to say that we have this great
job this kind of crazy thing but we
don't want to do like the dirty gritty
thing to actually make the money Dirty
Jobs that's how I got my position
so I have a question guys all right if
you had to go like go down a standard
deviation IQ
but you get a perfect body for the rest
of your life would you do it
body is you get it like Frozen in Time
the rest of your life if I did a key
thing I 100 would do it I'm a smart ass
no you would have to go down
you're Dumber now oh no that
guy oh okay so you keep the IQ what
would you do
um
I want somebody else to go next
you know what to be honest
I know what it's like the brains because
I have it now so I'm going to already
have I'm gonna go with the brains okay
you'll keep the brains what about you
you know I think I'd keep the brains too
because hopefully I'm smart enough to
make enough money to buy my body
that's okay what about you
um
[Laughter]
so I don't care to have my brain so I
guess I'll go down and keep my body
looking good
and you get a smarter guy you know what
I mean
I mean or you know
I'll do the body that's fine I am so
annoyed by stupid people I would never
want to be one of them I need to be able
to carry a conversation but it doesn't
mean you're stupid just go down a little
bit right yeah yeah I mean you go down
like like a couple IQ points but you get
this perfect body so you didn't say that
at the beginning
but you didn't say it specifically
the percentage
[Music]
what percent of like 60 year old ladies
really have perfect bodies like you
would be like the hottest 60 year old a
70 year old right now I'm like at the
top of the cream of the crop so if I was
to drop a few I'd still be at the bottom
layer of cream yeah
I wouldn't be a dummy for a body but
like I can drop a couple yes
students like I've seen her doing an
amazing little thing with like losing
weight and like you could do it on your
own girl
the boobs like you can't get big boobs
out of nothing nobody a what I said body
no I I know when I lost it myself but
she said you could do it on your own I'm
saying unless you want to put like a
foreign object in your body which you
know or like about magic here
you ever wonder like how does that work
with like kids you know like
breastfeeding like it doesn't matter
it's so fun you can still breastfeed
yeah oh yeah isn't that like the plastic
because this is just how I think doesn't
the plastic
just go over it and like then the kids
like drinking like whatever the hell is
it directly out of the implant I just
can't imagine the implants like are good
for you no they're they they've actually
come a long way so I have like uh I have
gummies so it's like if if it pops it
doesn't leech but then it's like every
20 years all the women come forward and
they're like oh I have I think that
was the old silicone
but they just invent something new and
then 20 years later your chicks have the
same problem cyborgs and AI robots
they're going to be robots yeah okay
what about you perfect body but you got
to be Dumber I'm definitely taking
brains immediately because I'm always at
work like damn if I was so smart I could
just figure out how to AI this
yeah but but it's like we get the
perfect body
I mean me being smaller me being larger
I've lived both lives and I get
attention regardless I've always been
able to attract all different types
everything so none of that matters to me
physicalness is just so surface level
but for me if I have the brains to make
as much money as I want I mean because I
trade I do options I do Forex so for me
like if I had the brains truly to see
things on a different perspective I
would but then but then it's like if if
we were like the ultimate hotties then
you could just get a super smart guy
you know and then you wouldn't have to
think at all you could just be at home
chilling I don't want to get bullied
okay wait a minute wait a minute I I
have that option now so so it doesn't
really lead me more to it's like oh the
perfect body first of all just having
that man who is that man who takes care
of me I already have that so it does it
make me feel like oh I got to get this
perfect body so I can get the man that
sorry you're going to take care of me
but what about like keeping the man you
got what about it I got him well I'm
saying like wouldn't it I mean are you
married you said you're in a
relationship in a relationship right so
it's like maybe the perfect body he's
like ring right here no no I don't think
so I think it has to do with you I want
to go back yeah we're just talking about
you said something about uh what did she
just say I lost my train she said she
can attract anybody big or small anyway
and that she wants to be able to create
Ai and all types of stuff at work so she
doesn't want to lose her brains okay
yeah I can't I lost train of thought we
were my bad you made him a perfect body
just so I can look in the mirror and be
like damn it's fine yeah
not so I can catch a man or yeah
my girlfriend I wonder why this is like
got reaction of us women whenever it's
like we have with this you could have
this for a man it's so interesting
because we'll always have to say no no
no it's for myself but it's really
interesting because a family is supposed
to be selfless
families only work if we're selfless and
we're thinking about the other person
yeah and well and the husband and it's
interesting too because we'll give up
stuff for our kids and we'll do stuff
for the kids but it's like why why is it
a bad thing to say I want to have a
perfect body for the man
I think in like the whole like feminist
like movement of being like an
independent woman and even saying that
you're codependent on somebody it almost
is a negative tone these days but it's
not I mean technically you are you're in
a relationship it's okay to be
codependent on each other yeah like I I
would love a perfect body to get married
and then husband and then that's his
body like I think that'd be great like
what's wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with that's just how you view it
you know what I mean I think everybody
has to live with what they would feel
comfortable with so if she doesn't feel
comfortable with having a perfect body
but she feels comfortable with having a
perfect brains that's her mindset now
and what she'll live with right and
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
just more asking like why do we have
this gut reaction that anything we do
like for the men we have like whenever
girls say oh I don't put on makeup for
the men I do it for myself I don't do
this for the men like why is our gut
reaction as women like this is for
ourselves when if we want to be in a
long-term marriage you're supposed to do
a lot at least for him
guy grows a beard because his wife wants
him to is that equivalent to what you're
saying no because I think men and women
are different and I think women are here
to serve they have an exception that we
don't yeah because I think we're lied to
and saying that we're equal and I think
the natural order of the world is we're
not I think everybody should be living
for themselves in their own happiness
and that you should never be codependent
on your partner okay I think I
so these people talk about being
independent independent means you're
alone yeah you're not independent and
the relationship
I'm a provider protector my
responsibility is the king of the house
is to provide and protect for her not
controller right you brought something
up but like treat you bad there's always
there's always these exceptions I was in
a toxic relationship everybody's been in
bad relationships right but my duty and
responsibility and honor is to serve her
and and provide and protect for her
responsibility she takes care of the
home she cooks the food this is how we
live our life now when you say that if I
say I'm independent well then why am I
in a relationship right I rely on her to
take care of the home that's what she
does I didn't say independent did I no
but I'm saying you said codependency is
bad it's not codependent like you're
unable to like you can't survive
it's just being a team well no no no so
this is the other misconception a
relationship is not a partnership a
partnership is where you go into
business with somebody we're not in a
partnership we're in a relationship
but definitely it's not this is this is
where the problems come in we come in
it's 50 50. no it's not 50 50. I lead
the home but here we are right here we
are I believe it's 50 50. but this new
generation set of men is why a lot of
the women are the way they are with the
feelings of wanting to be so independent
because the men are like so aggressive
men are the new let me tell you
why women ask them to be and 80
of the single parent homes are women and
they're trying to raise these boys and
they're raising them as feminine men you
need to do this you need to do this your
grandma your great grandmother is like
you go go out find yourself a good man
that can take care of you a lot not and
when I say this a lot of a lot a lot of
these women nowadays their mamas are
like you don't need a man you can be an
independent boss and then what
happens is you you become 50 60 years
old drinking box wine watching Netflix
with your with your cats talking about
angel numbers and horoscopes I'm fine
but let me tell you something I'm fine
I'm fine and then you come 60 you're
like what am I gonna to do for work you
can't retire you don't also have two
three million dollars they picked if
they picked the perfect body at 60.
yeah there you go there you go I'm not
coming at you I'm just saying what what
as a man of a high volume man we're
looking we're like I I talked I had a
conversation last night I talked to
hundreds and hundreds of women I coach
men and women I get these challenges
I've helped marriages now I'm not
perfect
I don't know everything but I'm rarely
endowed because this is what I do and I
see the challenges that some of the
ladies and men have and a lot of these
men are simping I get it they're simping
and they'll come up like like Pearl
Pearl is in a situation watch this Pearl
was in a situation A guy watched my
podcast Pearl was on there he reached
out to her somehow shaped way or form
and he wanted to date her and like as
soon as he met her he goes I want to
marry you it turned her off he was
simping am I right yeah yeah I did
and these guys I said men stop chasing
women
stop chasing women what value does a
woman bring to the table I say that
order the relationship outside of sex
what do you bring to the relationship
outside of sex I'm hilarious
do men don't want to date comedians they
want to date models what
what if that was true
you're you're not that I also have a
girlfriend
yeah I understand well they're right
you're in a different relationship
you're in a different relationship yeah
but but you know for men it's like
they're not looking for funny chicks
otherwise you wouldn't see all these
comedians they're always single no
that's not true have you seen that Asian
comedian she just came out with a movie
yeah
she was pregnant she already had that
baby yes you know what's so funny it's
like you have to bring up the exception
whose name you don't I don't really
watch comedians well yeah but like just
I can't remember your name but I see
handlers by yourself all the big name
comedians are by them that woman is paid
I still do think like as much as you can
be as black and white with stuff I still
think that men do choose you or fall in
love with you more because because of
your personality and because of things
that you bring to other things that you
bring together they miss you when you're
not around not because you're fine
really nice bodies at that really nice
body is tatted up gorgeous I mean the
woman that all the men walk in the room
and want and they still get cheated oh
no we have a man in the room
what were you saying about the woman
tattered in the room say that again I
mean she could be tatted she'd be not
tatted but I actually know women that
are completely gorgeous bodies beautiful
faces intelligent bring a lot to the
table and they still are getting
mistreated and cheated on and pushed to
the side look at Halle Berry yeah but
here's the stuff
I'm sorry you want me to tell you about
Halle Berry I wouldn't touch her with a
10-foot pole that one was like a dude
masculine bossy as hell love it and
anybody gets to that just like Kim
Kardashian oh she's a boss she's
dude
like
returns
I used to hang out with Kim back in the
day so but but regarding this high value
men yeah look at Kevin Hart Jay-Z they
all cheated right but there's but guess
what she still stayed with him she still
stayed with them right so the question
is if you were in a relationship with
Drake and married to Drake and you
cheated on you would you still stay
married to him no why do you guys get to
have such a high body count and women
don't that's my big problem and like I
don't know
hold on and get away with everything
wait hold on let me just finish with
everything
we're now like
um
I don't really do the whole like
sure I don't have a lot of bodies up
under me but I still stand with women
which don't judge a man like don't not
judge a man when he has a high body
count but if a woman who the
she want because she can because she's a
bad why the you calling her a
hug okay first of all you don't have to
be a bad to a bunch of guys
any girls every girl in here
women right now can get on the phone and
have sex tonight yes right it's very
hard for men you can just walk out down
the strip and be like sex
you know what I'm saying yeah it's very
hard for men a lot of women don't
believe this is very hard for men to
have sex with women I've heard men say
that it's very challenging let me
explain something no no ten percent of
men are actually sexually active a lot
of women think all these dudes and then
and the 10 they're sexually active
they're the ones having sex with y'all
you see you see what I'm saying yeah so
what happens is for a man to go out and
have sex for him to have access to women
and and have options he's got to be on
point High valued have status have swag
he's worked hard to get to that level
now to answer your question on why is it
bad when a woman gets past six men body
count her her pair bonding starts her
ability to pair bond with with a man
goes down to 25. we should learn this I
read psychology books on relationships
people that have interviewed ten
thousand people specific specific number
yeah let me let me explain something
your oxytocin levels go down it's hard
for you to pair bond with a man the more
men men you've been actually I can speak
on this okay but I'm going to have Pearl
talk to you but that's a good question
for 21 years you think it ain't but
you're not with that you're not you're
not with a man you have a choice right
yes but my to my point it's you'll see
women go through guys or go through
relationships have problems it's hard
for them to bond well I okay so I I
agree that we are we should be saving
ourselves a little bit better than what
we do these days yes okay whatever who
cares but I I don't believe in this pair
bonding thing and I only say that is
because oxytocin is something that gets
regenerated in your body sure and it
actually gets regenerated super quick
like after sex I have a question do you
think that a virgin and a hooker have
the same hair bonding abilities so yes
sir okay my question also yes or no
I think it's the same I do not but I
don't believe so you do believe it to
some extent yes but what I'm saying is
the science behind actual pair bonding
in the six partner thing I don't think
that's actually true science and I only
say this is because I try to read up on
it because I was actually curious about
it and they said that they they got this
um information from a mammal called the
Prairie Bowl have you heard of that so
this whole thing that you're talking
about with six Partners actually came
from a different mammal that was not uh
not like well and we could we could
argue it's time we could argue it's 50
hours but we know but we know what's
true is the more you sleep with the
harder it is but I also believe that has
it's yes it's hormones but it's also
trauma it's allowing people people in
you can also but it's like it's like
okay if I drink every single day of my
life then alcohol is not going to affect
me everybody yeah as much if you if you
every single person you meet it's
not you're not going to bond as much to
each one yeah so I'm not saying six is
the number it could be ten
I mean women lie anyway who knows what
those chicks body counts
so I used to be a cocktail waitress at a
strip club right and they used to always
tell me why aren't you gonna be a dancer
and I said I don't want to be because I
feel like me just it's just a me thing
you have to be an actress and when a guy
comes in I have to figure out what role
am I playing in his life to receive that
money so I was nervous that I was gonna
mess my mind up when it comes to a man
that's coming in my life and I'm like am
I going to switch myself for this person
and not be who I am and then inevitably
they're going to see the real person and
we're gonna have an issue so it's gonna
mess I guess the pair right but the
whole point is that less is better right
in general
save ourselves a little bit more because
I think we're just yeah
honestly but I just want to put this in
a historical point of view you know a
hundred years ago what percent of women
were virgins on their wedding days 100
years ago yes probably almost like 100
of them yes like 90 90
85 percent of women yeah virgins now
let's just say because we all know women
lie so it's like all right let's double
let's double A version on my wedding day
if I would have been you know in a
sexual assault as a child you know and a
lot of women go through that and that's
that's unfortunate when you go through
that as well I was raising a very you
know religious household I would have
loved to get married and you'd agree
that would have been the best out I
agree right I agree but unfortunately
there are people who are monsters out
here and they and criticize those women
that are virgins they take that
innocence no I don't think that's the
majority I think
I think the majority of us women we meet
a guy that's handsome and we just yeah
we I think in general yeah like
it's it's not also and so in a way in a
way like women in a way women we're the
ones picking non-monogamy because when
we have the most Choice which is early
20s we don't pick monogamy so you're
right right yeah no no you didn't I mean
first I will pick well no you you didn't
because how old are you again I'm 28.
okay you're 28 so you could have I know
I know you had that happen to you but
after that you could have had 18 20 22
picked a guy gotten married stayed with
him and you did it none of us did and so
so from when it would have happened but
it didn't happen right but that's that's
the point it wasn't a priority to you so
in and not necessarily wasn't a priority
it just wasn't I didn't meet anyone well
made that happen right it's like what
it's like but it's like if we if we put
that towards well I should have been and
I was chasing college sports like that's
what I was doing I was checking that was
your priority and correct and that's
what I'm saying like when we have the
choice we don't do it and so in a way
it's like we're the ones picking
non-monogamy and we whine because when
the men don't pick monogamy later Asia I
want to hear from you you haven't said a
lot is it what are your thoughts on this
my
I guess what I can say is I I'm divorced
so I'm 25 and I'm divorced and I did
choose monogamy young I was we got
married when I was 23. and
why did she stay married
why didn't I yeah
I did something I I got divorced because
I
couldn't compromise because my
ex-husband he he was an alcoholic so he
didn't want to stop drinking he I tried
everything that I could I tried therapy
I tried
offering services but you can't change
what somebody did you know he was an
alcoholic when you married him no I
didn't there's no warning signs was he
an alcoholic when you married him or did
that no so it gradually got worse as we
after actually afterwards was it like
work related like that he wasn't able to
provide like that so it started to get
on him because I know that about that
happened well he he's prior military he
was deployed he was in combat and he had
yeah he had yeah and in the beginning it
was regulated with medication and it was
good you know but after a while like
sometimes definitely you know what I'm
doing now yeah we still have contact
even it's okay or better or what he's
right where I left him yeah
unfortunately yeah
wow I don't blame you one bit for
leaving that yeah no I end up
environment yeah it wasn't
nice with any longer and
stay with him I did and I would have
done anything that he needed but you
didn't stay with him so how could you
say you did everything you could to stay
if you left I'm not I'm not even saying
you're wrong for it but I'm saying like
it's kind of not true because you know
women used to date alcoholics for like a
decade and then they'd stop they would
just like stick with it I'm not wasting
time
I'm not what I'm not pushing back on is
saying oh you shouldn't have left that
or whatever what I am saying is like
this idea that we did everything you're
there like what I guess what 25 so I was
like six years yeah but what is the
timeline for that exactly
you know I'm I'm Catholic so I don't
believe in divorce so I actually I think
it's like for richer for poorer for
better for worse and sickness and in
health so I don't I don't believe in
divorce so if somebody was manipulating
you every single day women are usually
the more manipulative ones anyway I
think your dad I think we would all be
in a better place if our dads helped us
pick husbands because we don't pick very
well clearly my dad's not here yeah
[Music]
well if you wanna if you want to talk
about the dads then like the moms picked
the dad you're you guys dad so it's like
if they're how many I think we need the
dads involved how many of you grew up in
a nuclear family like a mom and dad at
home before they passed away before they
passed away okay to you okay all right I
come from a broken home yeah I have to
pretty much build
what I had in regards to what my
preference this could be yeah yeah and
that's really not sad and I think again
because it'll go to our parents right
and a lot of our parents didn't pick
well either like well I wouldn't say
that I didn't have that type of guidance
I mean I definitely have that
relationship with my dad where I could
bring him I did bring my dad to or bring
my husband to my dad at the time you
know and your dad was like this is a
great choice he thought he was great he
thought he was and he probably was but
into the PTSD and everything else right
there's a lot of factors that play into
it okay and so he just started drinking
and then just became an alcoholic and
two starters he was drinking because how
long were you married we were together
we were together for a year we were
married for two years okay so we were
together for all in all three years okay
and good job for getting the out of
there thank you you're welcome you know
at the end of the day too he's it's he's
a great person like I'm not knocking him
on that at all like that's one thing
that's one of the reasons why I loved
him everyone on this earth needs to put
their own happiness first above
everything wrong I think you got to put
your hands last if you are I think how
can you pour from an empty cup I think
that's just nonsense feminist garbage
basically it's for people no no for
women it doesn't matter you're gonna be
unhappy in marriage at some point you
think our great grandmothers stayed
together for 50 years 60 years thinking
about themselves you know how I could
tell the generational switch you can
hear it in the music we got the Taylor
Swift generation which is I'm a victim
blah blah blah where do you remember do
you remember the song Jolene you
remember the song I love that song no no
but that's how women used to react I'll
take please don't take my man because
because she was worried that her man was
cheating and instead of keying his car
which you know Carrie Underwood King is
what she
no but she stayed with them I heard her
talk about that and it's like it was
just a completely different mindset
where she's like I can't live without
this guy where now it's like women we
just care about ourselves and our
happiness and if the outcomes were good
then why aren't families together and
you know I feel like social media has a
lot to do with that too because there's
always like somebody on the back burner
or someone we've been eyeing or somebody
else who we know we could get somebody
that's been liking your pictures for the
last two years
that's the outlier that's the guy friend
that none of you want to be with but
he's a nice guy and he's the guy waiting
on the outside the guy that's liking all
your pictures and oh but he's my guy
he's the nice guy but that's not my guy
raise of hands who here has been in a
relationship and had a backup plan raise
your hand just ever in general
my relationships last like three months
old so I've never gone I have never gone
into a relationship
so I've never had a backup plan but when
I found out that they did something I
could have either chose to leave it or
chose to get back and that's the only
kind of backup plan that I've had it
never initially have you ever dated a
guy friend no yeah I have yeah yeah I've
never dated a guy if you're ever if
you're a friend of mine my eyes
it got like it got snuck into me because
my best yeah yeah it's all right yeah my
best friend is just committed so I like
felt like very like vulnerable and
that's how my best okay the guy friend
got to sneak in there okay well that's
not that's not that's not a guy friend
I knew him four years and we didn't do
anything and then like when my friend
passed away and he was being there for
me then it kind of but when that guy you
know what he was always thinking about
that wait he was my friend for four
years he doesn't discredit the
friendship he never do you know why do
you know why they're guy friends I think
that if you're gonna be able to sleep
yeah hey no no do you know why they're
guy friends
okay they're probably waiting for the
chance but we never went on a date they
never know because you told them they're
their guy friends I did yeah they're
that's the only reason she gets it now
and so as a guy as a guy if I'm dating a
cat oh I got five guy friends I'm like I
put the brakes on right I'm like wait a
minute I got a bunch you guys I'll say
this women pretty women always have a
backup plan pretty women are never
single women nowadays it used to be
nowadays women always if I looked at
your IGS
and your inbox your DMs you got backup
plans you just don't know it but you
know you have backup plans
most men they don't get DMS from chicks
right hold on what because I've been
checking my like my ex-boyfriend's
phone and it'd be all kind of DM
that's because
they're getting married but you hear
what I'm saying you hear what I'm saying
like you guys get it you guys get body
part picks you know what I get it's a
joke it's a joke I made fun of cats so I
get pics all the time I get cats I
bet it's cats not yeah so I get people
sending me cat jokes because I made a
joke about single women angel numbers
horoscopes and cats and box wine but I
think they're so unattractive women send
dick pics yeah but we don't like that oh
my gosh please don't hate it like when
they send me a shirt for anybody who's
listening like girls only like dick pics
when we ask for that dick if you ever
send an unsolicited dick there's no
woman like I'm
you know
yeah and um dick picked to us is very
perverted it doesn't seem attractive
okay now you know how men think men are
fun football food and we're
simple yeah we're simple creatures a
habit right men men are always looking
at women as a sexual object the perfect
body right that's why she said that guys
don't care about your degree right you
guys don't care about your money now if
they're simping and they're like oh
she's she's gonna be my Sugar Mama but
guys first look at the look at the woman
she's hot whatever's in the desire of
the guy it's actually what he likes and
and he's gonna look at her now looks is
also objective there's objective truth
to that what beauty is but not
subjective but objective so guys are
like okay we think with our testosterone
we were put here to breed procreate
women look at a guy and they go for the
resources not money when I say resources
you're gonna have children you want the
best outcome and probability for your
family to have longevity right so you're
not going to date no scrub
or continue a relationship especially
when you're looking to have those things
right can you date at your level and
above you always dated your level and
above right no no so she only cannot
level up okay no not with her so so
here's the challenge here's the
challenge inherently you inherently okay
and again I'm gonna go back to my data
okay Dr David Buss has a book called The
Evolution of Desire five years of
interviewing ten thousand people all
over the world different religions
ethnic backgrounds whatever and the
number one response that women look for
in a man was resources so that's their
level and above right because what
happens what happens biologically you're
looking for somebody better than you
want a man that's a hero right you want
a guy that's successful doing what he's
doing when you date down what happens
you lose respect for that index okay
remember when she dated or did well
JLo's got a bad record as it is right
but she dated her dancer I'm like that
he's she's paying for everything yes
yeah right and if I need it if I if I if
I work no pun intended because I can't
say UPS those guys make 170.
yeah
hey when you when you drive this is guys
this is guy's mentality to a point
you're driving up to the in Seattle The
Latte stands we call them Bikini
Baristas and all the stands in Seattle
have the girls with the bikinis on the
lingerie yeah I would drive up and I'd
see a dude and I would just keep going
why I didn't go there for the coffee
you're right I went there for the boobs
the Coconuts the Coconuts with the
pasties so you know and I I started oh I
want to go to um Dutch Brothers and have
a swirl latte double Frappuccino latte
with a Twist pumpkin spice I'm like okay
is she hot
Starbucks girls are hot they're wokies
right first of all for seven years
yeah they're socialist stuff that's
crazy I was thinking about this as women
we don't realize as a group how much we
suck I think that women suck as a group
nowadays compared from a historical
point of view because nowadays a hundred
years ago a guy would have got a virgin
she would have been in shape she would
have had the mentality of she has to
serve him so she was helping on the farm
she had five plus children
nowadays it's like 90 percent of us are
on birth control 70 of us are overweight
um we don't get married till we're like
31. so as a group unfortunately
we're just not doing that well from a
historical point of view we all would
have been thrown out a hundred years ago
we even had to learn instruments to play
for when our husbands like friends came
over we had these cookbooks from scratch
and your husband could actually take you
to jail for nagging if you were nagging
too much you could be prosecuted yeah
on the other hand you could prosecute
your husband for not paying bills yeah
you would have been a virgin you would
have gotten married you would have been
raised to be a wife but nowadays we have
all this like programming that basically
tells us to do it on your own and it
produces bad wives go ahead I was going
to ask you so you know how much has
changed for as far as what women used to
offer men as a wife but it's changed the
same way for us as far as what men have
to offer us
so I disagree you don't have a bunch of
heights I disagree I disagree on why you
don't sell because you don't know what
they're looking for so the issue
so I I I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell you why I disagree okay I'll tell
you why I disagree because typically
like what do women typically bring to
the table like like from a marriage
contract you're usually you're supposed
to traditionally be a virgin you're
supposed to traditionally be able to
cook clean you're supposed to
traditionally have a lot of children
right
how old are you 28. not really but like
okay
my Grandma had 13 children you can't
have 13 kids
okay so oh my God for you right but I'm
saying from a historical point of view
if a guy wanted to get 10 kids from a
chick it wouldn't be that hard to do it
that's damn near impossible unless he
has bought multiple baby mamas today
dude okay just question do any of you
want to have 10 kids hell no
they still offer like they still offer
protection and provisioning because we
live in a society where men will protect
us you can walk alone at night in a
major city
and man you're not even married and men
will still protect you you can call the
police you can we have the military
protecting us so they're still
protecting us they can buy a gun and
protect you
um provisioning you know women are a net
tax loss meaning we spend more than we
make so yeah so so we already get we
even get provisioning Just For Men as a
whole from the society we have all these
jobs we're either monetizing beauty or
we're working for a man that employs us
so we're getting protection and
provisioning even without a husband but
if you go to a husband men still make
more they spend less they're better with
money so you still get provisioning and
protection they're still stronger than
us and if they're if they're not you
know super strong they can go buy a gun
I think in Vegas right they can't hear
him so so you can so wait from The
Exchange we're not bringing Purity we're
not bringing youth and we're not even in
shape or the men are still giving a bare
minimum protection and provisioning our
argument is so flawed because back in
the day 100 years ago people were
farming they needed to have kids to put
them to work and most of them some of
them didn't even survive so they needed
to have 10 just to Hope five of them
were gonna live so long to pick from the
field now times have changed
okay we're out of school for summer
because of harvest season no no that is
why kids are out
I need you to talk about like what time
period you're talking about so 1800s no
okay okay so you don't even know the
time period
so like factories came in the late 1800s
and still people still had five plus
kids early 1900s because it wasn't as
used to what was traditional but here
now the tradition is having two or three
you don't have to have ten kids
and whose choice is that it's ours as a
whole we're overpowered whose choices
just in general like you can't really
afford 10 kids right they cost a lot
more poor people have more kids than
rich people yeah
[Applause]
who who controls access to sex men or
women
it's a women's fault not the men unless
they're a rapist which is very good that
doesn't happen a lot
if I pull the stats up she's talking and
I tell you you're going to say faster
not only what's been reported yeah
exactly I do I do I do understand what
you're saying in the perfect world if we
have all these high-value men walking
around we should be a strong way okay
great no but wait we unfortunately don't
well sorry I have to say I'm not trying
to uh interrupt you uh so my mom did not
raise me to be a wife she raised me to
be an independent independent woman
because she had dated such terrible men
that acted like they were going to be
this provider this person got married to
them or end up having a kid and then all
of a sudden they were abusive alcoholics
she's lying this whole thing you know
this is my mom's experience and I know
my mom is not a liar
she's probably lying they usually lie
yeah no that's like because it's like
right now no no she'll say that no I'm
not saying it's your mom oh yeah but a
lot of women then you hear the other
side of the story
if it's more than one guy she's the
common denominator
is like no I don't think it's
picker she's probably abusive like
because it's like what what do the women
do to bring this out of the men if it's
multiple men that means she's probably
doing something why why is it that like
you if you feel that we're doing
something to Pro it's almost like it's
almost like oh because no no what you're
saying to me is like I walk down the
street just looking like this and I got
raped it was your fault because I look
at you
later because when women when women get
power we're not benevolent when men get
power they are if if men wanted to we
could all be sex slaves in caves right
now in cages that's what happens when
men get power when women get power we
tend to abuse men we would destroy you
has anyone how are you gonna make more
men
I I would rather kill a baby
than you make me have a baby
let me get this straight you think you
would beat him in a fight really oh yeah
he's gonna he's gonna impregnate me when
the baby comes out I'm killing that
no no no no no no no no no
it's not coming out so how are you gonna
have babies without women how are you
gonna have babies without women
dominate women no matter what oh hello
right hello everybody over here is
agreeing yelling hold on hold on what
she was saying is who's going to take
control in a situation a man or a woman
we can overpower women physically we can
dominate if we wanted to so if we had if
we wanted to we could take control if
there was if there was physically right
yes not mentally so whatever so go back
go back to your statement about it yeah
because men when men get power we're
naturally benevolent when women get
power they're not and the problem is we
have an entire general generation of
daughters and sons that have been told
their dads were the bad guy and usually
they're not and I understand that I do
actually agree with that it's happened
my mom was actually really good at like
not instilling negative thoughts about
my father and allowing me to understand
who he was I think what Pearl was saying
and not to not to attack you or your mom
but if if in any situation even a man if
a guy's like oh I've been in 20
relationships and all the women were
abusive it's like okay whoa what did you
do there's an exception but I've seen
ladies that have been in relationships
time and time and time again and been
physically abused and I'm like okay
first of all men generally want to do
that but that particular woman she's
doing something I'm not agreeing I'm not
justifying that the guy should be
physical but so 10 more lights hold on
hold on hold on let me finish 10
relationships what the are you
doing to cause these men to get violent
with you well I'm not doing anything I'm
not doing anything no you are the
problem
no I
well I'm just thinking like like what
okay so he comes home and he just says
I'm gonna beat you there's no argument
you weren't trying to control him
because I believe the natural order of
the world is God men and women and when
we try to confuse women and say we're
equal to men and that we have an ability
like that we should be able to control
men that's when evil happens equality
with men and women at all right right
but I think I think we're supposed to I
think we're supposed to submit to men's
Authority and I think when we don't
that's when evil happens and so
typically when when there's a
dysfunction in the family it's because
the woman was trying to impose her will
on the man look I I understand what
you're saying because I've been red
pilled like and I I'm 100 out of famous
I do believe in the red pill I think
you're a little bit more extreme in the
mentality of it hell yeah
I'll say this my first my first so I
dated a guide five foot four he did have
a really nice body great in bed five
four five four no job wow
but after school everything I wanted to
be better I did submit to him but he
didn't deserve it but I did and I did
start getting the disrespect I started
to disrespect him because he was not
but
but that that's what go ahead but listen
so this is my first my first thought
when I was laying in bed and I lost my
job ended up going under and I was like
like I have no money to take care
of this person next to me and me if this
house is burning down I'm gonna have to
put him on my back my dog in my hand
like save us both wow I was like it was
the biggest pressure I've ever had and
then I thought to myself if I have to
make this person my long-term partner
and get married correct what if I what
if I need to be bedridden with a with a
child he cannot take care of us and he
doesn't have that mentality of you know
what I'm gonna go shovel on the
corner just to make sure that this house
is going to stay above her head so I was
like this is the most stressful I've
ever been I will never do this again
ever a day in my life so I that day
forward I understood the dynamic between
a man and a woman and how I do want a
man to make more money or to be a little
more responsible to be very dominant but
the the issue we have with a lot of
chicks is we're living outside of our
lifestyle means so like when you have
kids you're kind of supposed to go down
in lifestyle like I have a friend she
had four kids kids and she dated a guy
that was making forty five thousand
dollars a year and she relied on solely
one income they only had I know you see
she's like oh my God how would I do that
which is
the thing but the thing is no the
problem is women typically don't want to
go down in lifestyle for a family and
that was expected before they knew you'd
have to work harder to have like women
would work jobs even like with kids and
they knew they would they would get it
they would get married and they would
like work harder and still have less
because they had kids but the problem
now is like women we we have these
unrealistic like lifestyle expectations
because we've been living by ourselves
for so long I agree because I was like
you're providing your being what is it
you're being the man that you want in
your life yeah so you're providing for
yourself and I I do agree with that and
I think my mentality lately has like
okay I'm trying to be I'm very masculine
of a woman and I know this about myself
but I don't want to be that way right
like I really am trying to be more
feminine with a man have him have the
dominant role be like and I think
sometimes with women like have you guys
ever done this where like you'll date a
guy that doesn't have a lot of money or
like the nice guy and you're just trying
to like beat the odds so you're not
trying to be a stereotype of what women
think using his potential yeah and then
you're like damn I got in my ass
for this because okay yeah and I'm like
so then you end up becoming the other
stereotype where you're like I need to
date the guy that has more money or the
guy that does this or something well I
just wanted to say that um to your point
uh Pearl I understand back then family
was everything right and time has
changed to whereas though family is not
really a priority meaning that if you're
going through something with your
husband or maybe your boyfriend or
girlfriend you kind of keep it to
yourself because you don't want your
family or your friends to judge you and
you're making all of these huge
Decisions by yourself which is very hard
because you're not seeing it from
multiple uh perspective and again we
don't want our relationship Etc I don't
think it has to do with judgment though
because at the end of the day you have
to regulate how you feel about some
things no no what I'm talking about is a
support system so whereas though you
have a huge family you have a huge
support system maybe it is you know it
has to do with the church or with your
pastor Etc you have these people who can
counsel who can try to help you guys
before you do decide to say hey this
isn't working for whatever the reason
but today's society is more so who's on
my team yeah it's like oh I hate him you
hate him too or I hate her I you know
what I mean yeah so it's more so like
thinking about emotions instead of
thinking about the long-term effect of
if you do this you know the girls that
might say hey we're going to go slash
his tires you might have a crew of girls
that's down with that but nobody's
thinking logic is like okay we can slash
his tires they're social medias there's
ring cameras there's this there's that
and we all can go to jail and we may
have kids that we're going to leave
behind so it's so like emotional
thinking well and and I think you're
right that's why I say like a hundred
years ago there was there was five kids
and so like they all had families and
you'd all like raise kids together and
it would be like a community but now
it's like we have so many single mothers
and single mother homes where it's like
we don't have that community and that
Council we used to have and now women
are making decisions on their own and we
made the way and we make and we make
terrible mates mate selection on our own
unfortunately someone want to bring up
and it's interesting and again I'm not
going against the women but have you
heard of one female rap artist
that is positive
about men no no
what I mean unless there's conscious rap
you know let's say something here I'm
saying and so male's positive about
women exactly yeah so a lot of the music
of that same energy right that is Queen
Latifah said Who you calling a
right you know you and i-t-y
that's my point the culture and what
we're listening we got negative input
coming in we got people around us and
what happens is nobody is going to
anybody for guidance yeah on how to be
successful in what they want and it's
all about me me me right yeah and then
when you know who suffers the most is
the kids yeah the children yeah and then
they get raised and then there's these
problems and now what's happening is
there's no nuclear families anymore it's
almost a negative yeah right and it
should be a positive yeah you know and
there's so much like input like I
remember a long time ago I was like in a
relationship and then the guy put me in
my place because I was drinking too much
he had told me hey you need to slow down
and I think my friends had heard him say
that to me and I was like okay sorry and
then on the side he she messages me and
she goes wow you're gonna let him like
tell you what to do like that and
I think like a lot of like Dynamics
happen like that where we should be
listening because that's our partner if
if I was you don't know they don't know
the man that you know it sounds like a
good influence it's a good influence the
women only that my friends only trying
to control you right
well and the and the problem too is we
have a generation of really shitty wives
between the ages of like 35 to like 65
they're just not good wives and a lot of
them got divorced and a lot of them
didn't obey their husbands and a lot of
them didn't listen to their men and
didn't teach us what it meant to be
traditional because I I just don't see
modern relationships working I think if
you want to do it fine I got I got no
qualms doing what you want to do I just
don't see relationship like when there's
a kingdom right there's one king not two
if there's two kings they'd be fighting
all the time there's a reason there's
one and I think when there's two people
trying to have control and power all the
time someone has to give and
unfortunately nowadays it's more likely
to be the men because they're just
they're just tired of the women and
they're like a lot of guys will just
suffer yeah yeah there's a reason that
we have those phrases it's cheaper to
keep her because there's a bunch of guys
that they don't really have good wives
that we that we can learn from but
they're still married and it's just like
you know and they're and they're almost
like not even the king of their own
house and it's sad so I have a question
who who for you as a woman who's a
positive uh role model is a woman that's
well known who do you look at as a woman
that's successful and and has the
lifestyle you want
and the family you want in the marriage
you want who who do you look up to as a
woman what are you starting over here I
think that's really hard because you
really you don't really know people's
life you really you're not with them day
to day I mean what looks good on
Instagram and what looks good when
they're in an interview is one thing but
what's actually going on behind closed
door is very totally different like
everybody wants a happy relationship
right no one goes into it saying I want
a terrible relationship I want to argue
at least once a week I want to do this
even though that's the reality those
things are going to happen but it's how
you handle those disagreements how you
handle those arguments are you want to
call them a ass or are you
going to say something like you know
what my apologies you know whatever the
case may be so I don't think that I
don't look up to anybody because I don't
I realize that I don't know people's
real relationships and I always that's
why I always ask like the question like
will you obey your husband because that
really kind of tells you where someone's
mindset's at like could he tell you to
shut the could he could he no but
that's that's wrong it's like
it says in the Bible that your husband's
supposed to love you right and he
doesn't say love you when you're being a
perfect feminine woman most of us most
women today we're not perfect feminine
women yet we ask the men to be these
perfect leaders and will only obey them
when they're leading perfectly they're
not always going to lead perfectly life
is long but but the question is like and
then and then we get these like church
it's so stupid they they put propaganda
in the church in the early 1900s to
influence women that's why you have all
these single women in churches basically
saying that like you can only submit to
your husband's Authority um when he
follows God but then that puts the woman
deciding when he's following God and
when he's not following God but it's
like men have given us a lot of Grace
but we have no Grace for men
I was going to say I do um look up to
Jada and will believe me oh my God I
want to meet them
I think
that they open enough to understand that
sometimes you might have attractions to
other people and it's okay to make these
types of relationships as long as you
stay Partners together if I ever do get
married I would never want to get a
divorce even if we live separately and
it what about you
I don't particularly have a like a
celebrity or anything that I'm looking
up to there's just anybody like in your
life like maybe your grandmother or
something
um yeah I don't really have anybody that
anyone else I think Denzel and his wife
seem to have a pretty healthy
relationship but I don't know everything
sure sure but I'm like I'm talking about
a woman a woman but I love how like
they're in the charity how they like how
they're into charity how they like want
to like build together they're looked at
like in another platform I would love to
be at that kind of status I love the the
relationship and the camaraderie that
they have with each other I think that's
very admirable but again I don't know
everything sure it could be
horrible so my but my point is is
there's not a a figure out there right
it's installing positive messages to to
women I mean even Beyonce I'm an
independent I'm an it's like yes
[Music]
she's been married
that's my point you started off you're
telling all these women be independent
and you've been married she's the
biggest man
[Laughter]
Beyonce ass no more anyway sorry well
here's the thing even like a
relationship is when you go to work
there's rules right there's things that
you sign off to when you get employed to
say I will not do a b c d f and g
boundaries that's the same but when I
don't think people value that when
they're in a relationship because they
don't look at it as a job or a contract
but it actually is it's things in there
you're going to tell your man don't hit
me don't cuss at me or whatever your
boundaries aren't the things that make
you feel unconscious and something you
know it's Alice is really interesting
who who years in a relationship raise
your hand almost there three three okay
it's it's interesting because I can't I
can't oh my God I don't know what she's
saying it's interesting because I can't
tell the difference between women in a
relationship and not in a relationship
in this room based on like how
provocatively like you guys are dressed
yeah and there used to be a time where
like when when you got married it's like
I can't even tell the difference between
the wives and the mothers and the young
women that are single and signaling but
you know you're funny but wait a minute
let me just cut you off because I just
told her I said I wore a t-shirt here
because I thought there would be a bunch
of men here but when I found out it was
majority women in the room I took my
shirt off and she took her shirt off for
me
okay do you know what's interesting
about the way you guys you know what's
interesting the way you guys process
information is you process it very
personal where it's like about you and
I'm not talking about any of you
individually but I'm just saying as a
group like I can I walk down the street
and I'll see women holding the hands of
a guy dressed like a hooker I'll see
wives and mothers on Instagram dressed
like thirst traps and it's like where
are we as women in society if I can't
tell the difference
I just think it's just two it's 20 23.
if I was the guy that I'm dating said to
me hey when you are not with me or I
don't like that you're dressed like that
then I would change but but the thing is
if there's not an issue there's no but
the thing is like men will study us to
figure out what we want and then adjust
accordingly like they'll be like okay
like they don't like it when women don't
like when we do this this and this but
women type of Realm not right I mean
come on do you know what do you think
we'd start by being in shape like that's
the one thing
so you're you're already processed
but I'm saying as a group 70 of us are
overweight let me tell you something
though they're the guys who are the most
in shape the buffest most cut up
dudes like fat okay
there's always some there's always going
to be someone there's always going to be
and see like it's like the personal
attack
people are married look at sometimes
sometimes but it's never it's never it's
never to the men that you want they're
always these dorky ass dudes
even if you're skinny it doesn't mean
that like all of a sudden a guy's gonna
fall in love with you and be right to
you
know it doesn't make it easier I am
hot as I don't give a
what anybody has to say and I still deal
with the because a guy's gonna do
what the he wants to do because he
wants to
um I never said that right remember and
I'm not going to it okay okay is this is
this guy hot
his girlfriend is super attractive
because he's a high-valued man and he
wants a fit feminine attractive woman he
paid 38 billion dollars to get a divorce
to be with a Latina news reporter who
looks like a model for him to die hold
on high value men want fit feminine
attractive women
So when you say well I know guys yeah I
know guys too that'll be with a a woman
that's overweight or obese but the point
is the guy the guys that most women go
after this guy's not attractive
right he was at 7-Eleven with a name tag
that said Jeff Bezos on it you wouldn't
take a second look you know what a lot
of women go after this guy why because
his status because he has resources
resources that's my point so when you
talk to these guys we're all the high
value men they're with the pretty girls
they're the guys that have the Monaco
and the girls 19 21 years old and she's
got a brain of a box of rocks she's not
smart well and it's like if women didn't
know this it's like we spend thousands
of dollars on bbls boom jobs to look
younger like it's like women will spend
money to look younger smaller tighter
they'll go to personal trainers
like this is why like even though I
don't agree with you and I feel like a
lot of you the you say is stupid I
still like you
because like
do like say a lot of that I do
agree with and like people tell me I'm a
confused ass Republican all the time
they're like you believe in capital
punishment and abortion and all
this I'm like yeah but you know I'm
I'm not Republican uh you know it's like
you know just some like that you
know women shouldn't vote yeah
[Laughter]
it's so it's so funny we'll have this
whole combo and like I think by the end
it's like I'm showing why we shouldn't
vote
It's like because we can't even we're
arguing about his water wet do men like
thin chicks
let me ask you a question you don't have
to expose this or not yes
did you all vote in the last election no
no no I'm not gonna vote the next one
either yeah did y'all did y'all vote for
did y'all vote for Obama yeah yeah why
why because he's black but that's my
point
I voted because I don't want somebody to
run my country
what should I think about the emotional
part when you're here yeah voting yeah
you need to think about what that person
can bring to the table
what can I just say that my my grandpa
always told me vote for what you need
don't vote for what other people okay
watch watch this first of all he's not
black he's biracial he is he's biracial
black and white basketball but you're a
second of all just say no second of all
I have a dream that one day my children
okay will be judged by their character
not the color of the skin
because he was black but that was big
feeling
Forum based on facts and
it's okay I said that because I know a
lot that's the typical answer so
everybody normally says that however in
the black community when you have black
grandparents black mother black father
etc etc they tell you they explain to
you about Obama it wasn't just it was
somebody who you could relate to but you
finally but it wasn't just about his
skin color because we also voted for
Clinton we also voted Clint's black he
had a blow job in the office okay
I know
[Laughter]
what get blow jobs in their
office all day every day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
of men went to work and were offered a
you don't think they would take
it right now
in the office I said no that's
all guys that was a joke it was a joke
Clinton's black right he's just yeah
there you go that's what I was talking
about I don't know
y'all May hate women but y'all hate
black people but now
woke up now they're going Republican
a lot a lot but anyways go ahead that's
true that's very Hispanics yeah that's
very true if you were moderate back in
the day or like like you're more
Republican now well remember the black
party was republican from the beginning
y'all okay I want
do you know the history I knew she was
going to ask him okay but whatever all
right are you who voted you said you
voted
no oh you guys didn't vote you didn't we
voted for Obama but we did not vote I
didn't vote for him I was not old enough
to vote okay I did that time okay I was
just I'm just I'm just curious can you
name one policy from Obama
no I told you I didn't vote for him the
right way yeah you might you might you
seem like a policy of Obamas you liked
well like you know like he wanted to
like nobody passed anything he did
something for lgbtq rights right exactly
but that wasn't why I voted for him but
yeah that was the one the big one that
everybody voted for him because he
passed proposition eight but
that wasn't you know yeah yeah I think
gay marriage just got to be banned we
got a band yeah
oh
together
I don't really care who you guys
like do what you want why do you think
you're not him
I'll tell you if I'll tell you I'll tell
you I'll tell you because it's gonna be
on this thing okay the what do you feel
about transgenders wanting like
naturally born females that say you're
100 equal because I got a big old stand
on that wait what what you're definitely
born okay transgender I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna talk about the gay
marriage and then I'll and then we could
talk about the trans people okay I think
that we I I think that we should be
pushing policies that promote families
right now there's an issue where there's
below a replacement rate and I think
marriage is supposed to be a Sacrament
when I'm below a replacement so so you
need three kids roughly like you need at
least I think like half the women having
three kids to replace the population so
there's issues that happen in a society
when there is an aging population when
like there's basically too many old
people that can't work now the young
people are coming and we don't have
people to fill these jobs
paying people to move there because the
elderly are dying correctly so I think
we need to push policies that promote
family unfortunately you know gay people
can't produce children I know they can
adopt but these days they're such a long
waiting list for adoption it's Foster
they I mean they could but I don't think
that's ideal either because I really do
think you need a man and a woman in the
household that's just my my belief I'm
Catholic and I and I really do think
that marriage is a religious like
Sacrament and so I think when you're
kind of shooting and ruining the meaning
of marriage when you're you're having it
become between a man and a woman not a
man and a man or a woman and a woman I
don't really give a what people do
in their house like go have fun be crazy
you know what I mean but it's like when
you're taking something that's religious
and like calling it something else I I
just I'm a Catholic it doesn't say right
with me me and my girlfriend have talked
about it and if we did end up getting
married we would want us to find like a
high value man who was cool with being
our baby daddy you know what I mean
where she would be the one the
kids out I don't do it
um okay yeah we're being we would have
it
does it seem to seem like a good family
structure to you I'm good for the kids I
don't think it's any worse than well
we're raised by one moment I agree I
think I think that a single mother
household I think all the kids should be
given to the dads
yeah because I think if let's do what's
best for the kids and all of the data
will tell you that single father homes
turn out better than single mother homes
let's give the kids to the desk
I think I think again um it disrupts the
natural order of the world women we get
our periods we're emotional and so it's
like you know I just I think it's really
cool yeah especially young men you know
and that's why if you look at all the
problems in society we can go off of
data we could go off of what I see in
real life like there's a homeless
shelter down the street from where I
live in England and I asked them like
why like why are these people homeless
like what got them in this situation and
he said the number one reason is because
of single mother homes if you go to the
criminals it's the same you go to um
Juvenile Detention Center same thing if
you go to insane asylum same thing so
it's like we have this one common
denominator where single mother homes
have all the issues in society really
come from it and I I think that evil
happens when you disrupt the natural
order of the world and unfortunately
there's propaganda there's government
policies that really disrupt the natural
order of the world which is that we are
supposed to submit to men we cannot be
here without men they do all of the hard
jobs in society they make all of the
money in society it's supposed to go God
men women children so so on a single a
single black woman's home 74 of the
women that have children the single
homes or black women right in a black
household right so when they get
divorced 74 of the single homes or black
mother that the children are 20 times
more likely to go to prison
nine times more likely to commit crimes
five times more likely to be in poverty
this is data from the Census Bureau this
is the we're making up and so when
you look at that you you see what I'm
saying and I'm not look I don't hate on
anybody a gay straight trans or other I
hear what Pearl's saying but the point
is is that everything that's going on
right now is anti-prolife like there's
more black babies getting destroyed by
abortion than black children are being
born right now in America well I'm glad
that I contributed to society I have
four children I have three girls and a
son two of my daughters are married I
have three grandchild children one on
the way so like I've contributed to
society I have been a single mother I
have raised them and my children did get
married
um fairly at a young age and I'm good so
but that's good see that's an exception
do you think your your kids would have
preferred to have their dad around their
dad was around no do you think they
would have preferred to have two parents
in the same home yeah of course
absolutely okay so so you would like you
would agree yeah I don't think no kid
wants
there were times where it's like okay
for a short period of time it wasn't
anyone in the home but at the same time
I don't think like you know bashing the
the child's father or anything like that
to leave the door open for them to have
a relationship just because you didn't
have a relationship with them doesn't
mean that the children shouldn't and
that's a real problem we have because
women basketball women bashing the dads
and making them out to be evil when when
most of the time the women that do that
they're the evil well I can say you
don't think that the dads ever bashed
the women because I know personally
because men no they do do that my dad
bashed I also know my uncles That Bass
they're like baby mamas and everything
it happened I'll give you I'll give you
an example okay so I'm doing a
statistics no I'm not it's they're not
distorted um it's just based off of so
I'm doing a documentary on divorce and
and the thing is when you interview
people like hundreds and hundreds of
people you just start to see patterns
and the ish use women have all the power
in divorce courts and it's very easy for
a woman to accuse a guy of abuse with no
evidence so they'll say and the issue is
when feminists get into Industries the
first thing they do yeah the first thing
they do is they switch the definitions
of things so I'll give you an example
one thing they did that with was rape it
used to be forced sex what is forced sex
that's easy to tell someone's on top of
you you're saying no blah blah blah but
what they switched it to was sex without
consent that makes it subjective so it
was what is consent that makes it
consent like it's different for each
woman right and you it ended that so no
not now what happens is women infiltrate
Industries and they switch the
definition so what they did was they
they switched the definition of abuse
and they expanded it and they got sexual
assault they added in financial control
coercion all of these words that don't
really mean anything and women can go
into Family Court which is based on a
balance of probabilities which means
there's one judge not a judge and a jury
of his peers he doesn't get to face his
accuser and it's basically not like
normal Court which Inc Criminal Court
you need evidence you need to convince a
jury and and in family court it's just
one judge which you know you cry it's a
lot of way easier to do that and so what
happens is a lot of these women they go
to court they accuse the men of abuse
and then they basically say that the men
did a lot of things that he didn't do
and I've even seen cases where a woman
is trying to get a man to hit her and
she still got custody like that that's
how one-sided the court is and it's it's
uh because they actually raped them and
then they're like well what is what and
the question is what is it going to talk
about that what is what is rape and
that's the problem is they've switched
the definition where we don't even know
what it is anymore well Pro to go back
to what you were saying about how the
women can uh influence the children
because my father did have other
children and they can't stand like my
father because well he's he's passed on
now but they couldn't stand him because
of what their moms were telling them
about the dad but my mom never give it
gave me that Side Story even though she
had maybe similar experience to their
mothers but it did not stop me to say
that oh I don't want to have a
relationship with my father et cetera et
cetera so I do know that yes women do
have a lot of influence on like the
relationship between children so that's
just my personal experience like and men
just don't have the tendency to do that
like men suffer in silence it's a lot
more like there's things women use
social manipulation men are more likely
to use like physical well actually I
think the guys are starting to be more
like that because they're they're like
down low gay as and they just take
on such ass Tendencies well yeah
they do gossip and they talk well a
lot of times a lot of them I really
think that most evil comes from women
and I think it goes back to Adam and Eve
I know this sounds crazy but let me
finish because who did the serpent talk
to he's talked to Eve and and all of the
big changes that you see in society it's
all from women for voting for in my
opinion evil policies I think it's evil
I think abortion's evil yeah and what
they'll do is they'll show women and
they'll show they'll show women they'll
show women a video of a 12 year old that
can't get an abortion and we just run to
the polls we just we're like oh no not
the 12 year old even though that's like
very much an exception because women
were really easy to propagate with
social media and I know because I
interview all these hundreds of women
they tell me the same arguments that I
hear from all the different women and
from social media it's so easy to
manipulate us when we're not under the
authority of men because men are just
more logical beings the abortion thing
is really hard because like it depends
like if the girl was raped and she's 12
years old of course you you feel like
she should be able to get one but then I
see so many that are like 32 and
they're on their 18th abortion i'm like
can we sign up
you need to get arrested
what are the part where a one out of
three women has had an abortion and like
to me that's crazy that's crazy and it's
less than two percent or one percent or
from but also that it was qualifying
underneath an abortion though even like
Plan B like does that count that's what
I want no no plan B doesn't count okay
what about like an ectopic pregnancy
does that count as an abortion uh those
are so weird they're not rare they're
very common yeah
I think that's that's people actually
like pass away if you have if you have a
next topic yeah yeah but I think
compared to how many
of us there are it's not it's not fair
that it's all on the woman though
because the men have male birth control
has been a thing and they're like oh no
no no the issue the issue with male
birth control is like they made it they
Market it this is what they do they do
like this false propaganda marketing the
reason those men died from male birth
control or sterile yeah it wasn't it
wasn't what they're yeah yeah yeah it
wasn't like just side effects it was
isn't it
what a vasectomy is reversible I think
it's I think it's reversible after the
first year it comes the whole 50 less
reversible or something like that as the
time goes on okay so so basically though
my point is
my my my point is like I just think that
a lot of I think that comes like when
women when women get power we're not
nice with it we're not even nice to our
own kids we kill them that's a crazy
thing and that was before abortion was
even legal women were the number one
people to murder their kids in the 1800s
I think they murdered like 10.
depression well we always make up an
excuse and that's what the feminists do
is they'll just make up some excuse for
the women
but my thing is okay if we want to say
that okay women if we want to say that
women aren't as accountable as matter
there's some reason that they did it
then we're not equal and we have to have
policies acknowledging that we're not
equal but if we're going to say that
we're equal then be equal have the same
consequences as a man but we keep seeing
these women throwing their babies in a
dumpster there's no there's no
consequence for it
oh no she pulled a vape out of Magnum
uh it's interesting because I did this
research on you know who Margaret Sanger
is she started Planned Parenthood you
know why she started Planned Parenthood
it was a Eugenics or an organization
yeah she did it to kill him to kill
black I know yeah isn't that crazy and
then and then we it's like what are you
doing we really are going okay and I
don't want to make this a racial thing
but the black community is going south
so fast where children are gone they're
going south so fast
yeah and right now you see less and less
children being born and and what's going
to happen now I think all communities
are going south so fast
I'm just going out for what I'm seeing
so yeah
so like when we get older we're gonna be
in trouble everybody just wants to like
comments
I'm sorry I'm not coming at the black
community and I know you're part black
that's why I'm not like coming at you
saying like you're doing it on that I'm
just saying that like a lot of people
just always want to come I don't think
he's saying it at a negative turn I'm
saying we need to change we need to
change the way we think yeah now what I
will say is like as far as YouTube and
even like Yeta included with it because
we're on the same platform people come
at Yeta all the time and I want to
kill them all the time because
they're like you're not black you're not
your pigmentation isn't dark enough I
hate they say that to her and you guys
are two very light-skinned people that
are mixed as well I don't I don't
tolerate like people telling you guys
you're not black enough just because
your skin color doesn't say that
so I don't like it at all I think it's
and he you're actually both
kind of right because in the early 1900s
they developed propaganda basically and
they realized that propaganda could
manipulate policies in a nation and I
think the guy's last name was like
hershing or something like that and the
the two groups that they do manipulate
the most are women and minority myself
so a lot of the policies towards like
single motherhood all that stuff was was
propagated towards black the black
community first and then so you're right
where a lot of the trends are similar
towards like single mother homes and all
of that stuff but I do think it affected
them like first because not only that if
you don't do your own research or you're
not going around taking polls you're
believing in someone else's research
you're not even following up on their
research or contacting the people they
so that so-called actually participated
in a research so there's another way
where like they say you don't do your
own homework you can't really you don't
really know the truth so your future in
somebody possibly preaching someone
else's lives because you didn't do your
own pool like we're in the black
community you can ask 10 of your friends
you can ask 10 of your friends you can
ask 10 of your friends and figure out so
when you start polling or talking about
polls you're talking about these are 500
women in my community that I like all
y'all together have like millions of
followers so even with those millions of
followers of men and women you know you
y'all can start pulling yourselves so
you can bring your own statistics to the
table pertaining to your followers I
know and you're absolutely right because
what they'll do is all these um
organizations that are funded by people
with an agenda will produce these
studies that basically will tell you
water is not wet yeah and that's why
like honestly like as much as I do you
know site statistics and whatever I
think the best way that you can come to
conclusions is what is in front of your
eyes yeah like what what what do your
friends do like what what do we actually
see because every time I turn around one
of my friends or somebody's pregnant in
the black community so I don't know like
where the other statistics come from but
I know a lot of people don't you think
that's culture though yeah instead of a
race because exactly if you're raised in
a different culture a different aspect
and you know communities like you can be
black and raised in a different country
and have a different mindset I think
it's a it's a culture where you're at
right your product your Association
environment yeah just like in Africa
there's our different tribes whereas the
women build the houses even though here
yeah yeah
all of my everyone that works for me is
from like different parts of Africa but
okay I'm gonna pull it up while y'all
are talking so that I can show you I'm
not I'm not saying that that's the whole
popular but there is a community a tribe
or women Native American culture houses
they build houses for the community we
can talk about the lab after
African-American culture that like has
like you know they're like women like
meter like themselves in the very
beginning you know like that's like well
when you think about it matter like with
circumcision men are literally mutilated
all the time and no one cares people
just really don't have at all no no they
don't get the same sensation during sex
if they're if they're on purpose if
they're circumcised yeah no shade but
like what's the purpose well what's the
purpose of cutting a man like that's
that's what I'm saying like people
always have sympathy for women and when
things happen to women but they don't
really have sympathy
um
guys that are not circumcised they don't
clean themselves
almost every girl that I know that have
like hooked up with an uncircumcised man
got something because they don't clean
them that's not true
[Laughter]
you didn't listen to what I said I said
the ones that I know I've never said
like in the history because I don't know
every woman yeah but like the girls that
I know when they hooked up with
uncircumcised they start
having all these if the dog is big
enough it looks circumcised when it gets
harder yeah
I just want to do an equivalent here
like what if what if they mutilated
women and then when they said well like
maybe we shouldn't mutilate women the
ant the gut reaction was well women
don't clean their well enough
and that's a thing
I could smell a girl from the
bathroom I swear to God I could smell a
nasty okay okay I'm with you I'm
with you
my point is that's not the gut reaction
that we tend to get I'd be like oh no my
point is even though genital mutilation
is not that common across the globe
right compared to male mutilation
compared it happens but but my point is
that is that we're always going to bring
up the women and not the man
say no to stank you can clean that
there's plenty ways
so you said you're not in a relationship
right do you want to be in a
relationship yeah I do I'm moving soon
so I'm coming to the U.S not because
are you coming to the U.S for a man or
just to the U.S well the I guess it was
more like a long-term thought of like
where I want to have like a family and
kids so um ideally yeah why not English
and you choose here
um no I didn't pick where yeah
why not um I think a lot of times when
you go overseas you just see a lot of
stuff that you really miss and I just
think there's something about feeling
like you're at home yeah
originally so I'm from Chicago me too
I'm from south suburbs yeah well what
part Dalton the hood
hey I'm from oh block oh block I used to
live in Wheaton in Naperville like the
West suburbs we haven't moved to black
people
I'm from Dino like past Elgin
so you're away for her out yeah yeah far
out far out but yeah so I don't know
what state yet um I was looking at Vegas
what do you guys think should I come
here I think this is the best out of all
the places I mean I don't know yeah that
was actually my thought was I was like
how is it like a family out here
everybody out here is a pimp and the
school system sucks the school system
sorry I had to cut off everybody I've
been here the longest stop you stop
um it's not if you like no no y'all
if you like black be careful they
might be a pimp
um like I've I've dated like a lot you
know
no shade because like you you like the
white boys crazy exactly because she
she's saying if you want a pimp then and
I'm like girl we know what you right
though
I think it's where we live in the area
in the community exactly that's what I'm
trying to say in Vegas like a lot of the
the black males in Vegas
if you see a black dude in a suit most
likely they're not about that life
they're you know they got their
together
is really important to me so so you're
one of them she's in London right now
yeah race isn't important to me I don't
want to be pimped though okay yeah I'll
keep that in mind if I need a black guy
out here
I guess my question Pearl is yeah so
when you're moving to the U.S you're
looking to move to a place where there's
family oriented especially because your
religious status that you want that
Community
Alaska
that's where she's from I mean I'm not
like a country country person you know
like I just like the suburbs I've always
been a suburbs kind of girl like outside
of the city for sure that's what I love
about this well if you move to Vegas go
to Pahrump that's far
awesome
that's a really bad in real life
for free I mean not for free but like
like not without like breaking any laws
yeah oh wow what I really love about
Vegas that's okay but like I was gonna
say there's Dallas Nashville yeah
there's nice areas
the real life Bunny Ranch is in Pahrump
you don't want to go there
when people look at Vegas they think oh
it's you know the Sin City and there is
if you're in the city yeah but when
you're on that suburbs I I chose to move
25 miles north the New Vegas right Valle
Vista North and it's like you get up
there it's quiet but when you come down
into the mix you see everything and
there's nothing wrong with that affect
your lifestyle the point is it's all
it's all selective I like it here
because everybody comes here yeah I
don't have to go that's and that's
what I thought like with um the podcast
or whatever it'd be easier to be by a
city people come to yeah
there's a lot of a lot of the women that
meet husbands they're from out of town
the guy they might have met at a
restaurant and then they end up moving
like this this gal move to Dallas right
she moved to Dallas and so she was uh
yeah
anyway so he she she met him here and
she was a realtor here and then they met
at a restaurant and she ended up moving
to Dallas
so it's like your husband this is what I
tell people I honestly believe this is a
great place to live I don't think you'll
meet your person that lives here I think
they'll be from out of town who even
live here are not from here you know
people people who live here it just
depends on who you're around from here
are weird that's what I keep hearing
from a lot of people as well though like
I'm new here I moved here out in in from
in April so all right where'd you come
from I'm I'm from Alaska oh wow
extreme extreme heat
to the desert okay
um but Alaska yeah it's 15-1 there's 15
dudes to one chick in Alaska you cannot
go wrong yeah I got options but they're
not good options
no no let me tell you what she gets in
Alaska my name's Buck I drive a truck
and I like to that's all she got in
Alaska am I right
I can go fishing that's like biggest
thing like people tell me like you're
not gonna meet anybody who is from Vegas
that you want to stay with and be with
you're gonna find somebody who's from
somewhere else somewhere else so we're
gonna date that are you are you from
here originally you said you've been
here the longest are you born and raised
no okay okay I've been here I've been
here for 10 years though okay got it got
it okay so in 2015. nobody's from here
no isn't that crazy I moved here in 09
for six months went back to Seattle and
I came back in 2020 in November how did
you like Seattle because I heard they
had the highest suicide rate they do
it's like Alaska the highest
prescription and a person drugs if yours
it was cold or something well it's human
Gloom nine months a year and everybody
everybody's very cranky Spanky oh no you
know it's like time out you need to be
on a timeout get your Starbucks don't
talk to me but but
a successful man and detective go to
Seattle it's great because there's a lot
of guys there to make good money but if
you're a guy you don't want to go to
Seattle
oh yeah the oil guys on The Proposal
with Sandra Bullock and Ryan Reynolds
and I do want to go that was not found
in Alaska let me just tell you where the
were they Michigan I think
that's not what Sitka looks like okay
never mind I don't want to go anymore
hold on hold on Sitka is beautiful but
everybody knows everybody small town
that's Vegas
once I connected some of you on IG
you're connected to all these people I
know right yeah so you cannot and you
will find out a person real quick and
gonna get exposed is that fair yeah if I
connected with her she's sounds like
she's been here she knows a lot of the
people in the in the industry it's
probably like we have to say though
what they wouldn't have to say no
I'm just saying you're connected to a
lot I had a friend that went on uh FNS
or not a friend but acquaintance
um and it was funny because she lied on
there about being in a relationship and
these people end up like trolling her
and finding all her information out and
setting it to like Myron and saying like
she's totally married like in this
full-blown relationship yeah
that's happened to me I I can't say
that I don't want people to find out
because they will yeah yeah just spread
it out yes the truth comes out
eventually yeah like yeah always just be
honest I am you know but most
just be honest or just be secretive
I'm gonna drink my water in my mouth I
guess omitting information isn't
necessarily lying but that's awesome
you're not entitled to my information
about what's going on in my life period
nobody nobody can do it to that do you
do you think that's like a good attitude
to have in a marriage the mic but oh
sorry do you want to be married
no no
that is not what I'm saying because the
way you guys talk y'all don't ever want
to be married that's how I no no that's
not true yeah and in that way you just
perceive me of not wanting to be married
that's how I perceive you guys y'all
obviously never want kids or a marriage
or anything yeah I get it but like the
way you guys talk it doesn't seem why
are you in a four-year relationship and
not married yet exactly
let me explain that let me explain that
to myself I'll tell you guys myself uh
everybody explain that to myself
self-help therapy I'm all about marriage
under the the belief with God you know
you propose you go to a ceremony you go
to a pastor you get married I'm not
going to marry the government
the relate marriage now is owned by the
government there's a patent on marriage
the agreement is between the man and the
government and the second agreement is
from with the woman of the government
this is a fact they only they own the
patent on it there's no agreement
between the man and the woman this is a
non-common-law state right so we go get
married we go we go get go get uh to the
pastor go have the ceremony under God
like Adam and Eve there's no contract
right we're married in that sense but we
don't have a contract so if I say I'm
married and you guys Google and and go
look for marriage licenses he's lying
what does a marriage license with the
government mean that I I I'm not married
or married are you with me I'm with you
and so what happens with guys after a
while you start getting to the point
where like okay I've made millions and
millions of dollars in the internet or
the technology space why would I why
would I say here there's a 51 chance of
of divorce 56 chance yeah and 10 of
those marriages that are together just
for the children I'm gonna put five
million dollars of my 10 million dollars
up for grabs yep and if she has a bad
hair day I'm not going to move in the
basement with my mama because she ain't
in love no more right so I put her into
trust that she gets x amount if she goes
somewhere so she's she's Mexican we call
them Mexican marriage because her
parents are together but they're not
married with the government right gotcha
so I am in America committed four-year
relationship we live together I act
married we you see what I'm saying but
if I say I'm married and she's like you
ain't married I did my research contract
between you and her I don't date other
women I don't need to and when I was
younger yeah I had girlfriends I was
dating doing the thing I was flexing
trying to be like damn and then I got
older I said that's not a flash yeah
that's not a flex you know and now it's
like hey I got a great woman it's like
why do I want to ruin that opportunity
now she wants to have children but she's
a competitive Fitness bodybuilder you
can't have both you can't go down to
four percent body fat and have a period
or have you know you know what I'm
saying to be pregnant now when the time
comes she goes I don't have kids I was
like you got to stop competing yeah you
can't have kids you might have to stop
for a while before she can even get
pregnant right right and so that's our
relationship but I do have a 20 year old
uh son who's right back there right
there that's my son
I love that and then my daughter's 16
and and thank God for for my girlfriend
mentoring her the girl is just a
phenomenal she comes not baby mama
girlfriend she does too the ex-wife
but the point is nothing wrong I'm not
bashing my ex-wife at all she's a great
person the point is is that my daughter
will come to me and ask me questions
that I can't answer and if I fake the
phone junk and try to tell her what I
think I have to have my I said babe help
a brother out here she's asking me some
serious questions Chad what do you think
about this uh well there's a star and
Santa came here and then she's like I
got this
so anyways go ahead his girl's the best
I love that I love that so um to close
out the show I want everyone to rank how
mean I was on a scale of one to ten
starting there how mean um to be honest
you weren't mean at all I mean you lived
your life doing what you do having your
own research your own opinion and I
don't think anything is wrong with it I
think it's a healthy uh conversation and
that's just your opinion and I'm cool
with it cool how mean am I one to ten so
sorry be honest when it comes to
meanness I think you're a five but when
I think when it comes to correctness
it's a zero oh zero no shade all right
yes yes sorry go ahead I didn't think
you were mean at all I felt that you
were very opinionated and everyone is is
entitled to their own opinion and so I
actually appreciated hearing your side
because I've never spoke to anyone like
you so thank you
thanks for coming guys how mean am I the
queen
I never thought that I you know I've
I've never thought that I'm not I you
know me if I I'm not gonna lie I'll tell
somebody Myron whoever nothing I have a
problem admire I don't have a problem
admiring I'm just saying yeah no I I
don't agree so you know I don't you know
what I mean zero zero I think you have
extreme opinions but I don't think
you're mean at all okay okay so again
you can't get a one direct you know what
I'll give you the one thank you
so bad we are going back and forth yeah
I thought about it I was like maybe I'll
to get rid of her
thank you
you're done for chat she's out
so I mean yeah you might have been
annoying but you weren't
awesome I
I want to order you a red nose and a
rainbow afro wig because
as long as we feel the same way but it
was like a mutual oh yeah okay
not mean but
but no way yeah one to ten listen I've
known a lot of intellectual people in my
life
you know know it all's are annoying and
I know
I'm gonna give a song
because I always get this clip
everyone's like she's so mean but I was
like she called she she was calling me
names first
I was defending myself
it was just facts though could you sit
on the podcast could you see Pearl in
the sandbox at four years old you
redheaded
but wait a minute Pearl it's hard for
you to actually say any like Kyra and uh
yeah because they are on social media
they get this type of hatred people talk
smack about them all the time
that they can
they are neonated as well too yes
they're very you think you can hate
these people they acting calm today but
they get the worst you don't understand
this this is like a like a are you using
conservative content is that what you do
yeah
I'm sorry no I'm not conservative but I
don't do all out what it is is I'm just
unfiltered I'm unfiltered as far as the
way I talk to you I will tell you your
mom should have swallowed you
easily yes she will oh
yes I wish you guys were in London I'd
have you on as regular
touch on the show
[Laughter]
all right so we're gonna do final
thoughts so any final thoughts in social
media you want to plug
um start in there and then go around
yeah um definitely you can find me on
social media at set designer Raquel so
yeah you can find me on social media so
hit me up also Tick Tock as well too
Kyra Simone agency owner on bigo live
performing assets Talent
no Cairo Simone Oh
k-y-r-a-s-y-m-o-n-e I'm on beagle live I
own performing assets Talent iBook
um broadcasters that want to speak their
opinion the way I am unfiltered let's
talk about it let's like go ahead and
like you know broadcast whatever content
you want to tell me your story I'm down
with it whether I agree with it or not
period
you can find me on Instagram it's
Malaysia May and it's
b-l-a-s-i-a-m-e-i
tell them tell them the huge podcast
[Laughter]
I can't win
wow she emasculated me
I was in a modern world you know so a
black guy she can find me on YouTube
Black Ice reality check spelled how it
sounds
do people ever think you say black guys
yeah
so I said ice black ice and
that girl said did you say black guys
no that's what you were thinking last
night when you were going to bed but no
Black Ice reality checks
not me I like them white
um I mean I have an Instagram it's not
that cool but powerlifting underscore
giraffe so yeah
I am at yet a brown baby on Instagram my
Facebook fan page and on be go live Tick
Tock get a brown baby across the board
cash app Snapchat all of that
um and um yeah Joe Brown on my regular
Facebook page make sure you add the one
with the blue check mark thanks
the blue check
you can't find your Instagram Tick Tock
uh just a few social medias Annie are
you okay with two eyes underscore are
you okay
but are you okay like Michael Jackson
are you okay are you okay
all right guys thank you very much thank
you very much for coming I thought this
was fun
this is making me want to come to Vegas
some good content I like these spicy
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel make sure if you want to
work for the audacity Network right
there yeah okay
um make sure you DM me on Instagram just
probably things one we are moving to the
US I don't know where yet but so Vegas
yes um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel talk to you
next time